so over the course of the next hour I
will show you projects such as how you
can by simply attaching a single camera
to a piece of 3d printed plastic turn
that 3d printed plastic into a working
game controller I'll also show you some
brand-new work on how to help makers
construct circuits and give them
interactive debugging help for circuit
boards and I'm also going to show you
some new augmented power tools that can
give you real-time feedback on the types
of tasks you're doing basically
downloading instructions into handheld
power tools but why right what is what's
the purpose behind these these tools and
who are we trying to help with these so
as the title of the talk indicates
interested in building design tools for
the maker movement so maybe we should
just start with a brief summary of what
is the maker movement well it's really
this bottom-up effort to engage people
from all ages and walks of life in
learning how the world of products and
electronics works and gaining hands-on
skills to actively participate in in
shaping that work so take this starting
workshop that was in Detroit here
there's really a variety of certainly
different ages and different experience
levels all trying to be a more active
participant in our material world and of
course ground zero for all of this is
the San Mateo fairground and Maker Faire
is actually this weekend it's starting
today so if you want to meet your
hundred thousand closest friends who are
all interested in in building and
tinkering and experimenting head to San
Mateo this week and so this has grown
from the very first year when I
presented the work that Michael and I
were were working on to a crowd of back
then it was 20,000 people to now they're
well over a hundred thousand people who
make the cemetery
and more than 800,000 to make it to
these events worldwide now the maker
movement is is happening outside of
academia but also inside and so hacker
spaces or maker spaces are appearing in
high schools middle schools and and
college campuses so I want to show you a
little bit about that as well but maybe
we'll start about start with just the
question what is it that people are
making what do we mean by maker movement
so you'll see many examples going from
the whimsical this is the the banana
synth that plays music when you touch
bananas to you know artistic robots this
is spin bought this is a project from
one of our lab managers at at Berkeley
kind of a gentle and an aesthetic
introduction to the structures and also
electronics behind robots to the more
technologically advanced so this is
super awesome Sylvia's watercolor bot
which is basically a CNC robot that
happens to draw with with watercolors
instead of having some other industrial
end effector at the end and here's one
of my favorite projects here these are a
bunch of teenagers who together with
with their parents and various mentors
built a full flight simulator into a
salvage salvage Cessna cockpit and the
flight simulator actually was mounted on
gimbal axes with complete 360 barrel
roll ability and hooked up to flight
simulating software this department at
Pixar I don't need two rows you're very
cool family yes so maybe we can see some
similarities here so from an engineering
perspective there tends to be this
confluence of software electronics and
also some mechanical engineering in many
of these project and often they're
they're not products per se but really
prototypes custom one offs we're making
one
is is the end goal all right well that's
certainly nice for all those makers but
what's at stake for us as a as a larger
community as a nation why should we care
about supporting the maker movement and
I'd argue there are at least three
related reasons there may be more one is
educational so let you read this quote
from Alan Watts we're just points to
that you know our educational system is
very good at equipping us with
analytical skills but maybe not so good
at imparting the motivation for what we
need those analytical skills for in the
end and so one of the promises of the
maker movement in education is that it
it serves as a motivator and also as
kind of a grounding application of stem
and steam skills and just to you know to
admit I have actually seen electrical
engineers enter graduate school at UC
Berkeley who are completely excellent
mathematicians but don't know how to
hold a soldering iron and so this this
may be a counter acting force second
argument is made by Erich von hippel at
MIT which is that often innovations come
from lead users rather than out of R&D
departments at large corporations and
the maker movement and the associated
tools can hopefully equip more lead
users to act upon their insight in a
particular domain so think about burton
snowboards right the biggest
snowboarding company was created by
snowboarders and over then over time
grew into a really big company but is
really the same is true for various
medical device innovations it's really
the people on the ground involved in a
sport or in a profession know what they
need and if you give them the tools to
to kind of scratch their own itch then
that can give rise to new companies and
new economies a third related argument
is about knowledge about manufacturing
in
united states so Denning wrote an
article why Amazon can't make a kindle
in in the US anymore which argued that
you know the decades of outsourcing have
actually led to all of the important
know-how in manufacturing to also move
along with it so it is much easier these
days to take your idea to shen jen and
learn about the local supplier ecosystem
there then try to do the product in in
the US now how can the maker movement
change that here's just one example this
is a type a a local 3d printing company
and they built the first their first
hundred or so products basically in a
tech shop or other fab labs here in the
area out of laser cut plywood and and
hardware store hardware and that allowed
them to gain enough expertise and
capital to then now manufacture
something that looks much more much more
polished and can be mass manufactured so
the white house has taken note starting
in 2014 there was a White House Maker
Faire coming up in June there's another
national Maker Faire in in Washington DC
so this is I think for some of the
reasons I just outlined starting to be a
national priority to support these
efforts because of education innovation
and just manufacturing knowledge now
another question you might ask is does
the maker movement need research do they
need the help of HCI computer scientists
mechanical engineers or are they just
fine well I would of course argue that
there is interesting research to be done
in to be contributed here for a number
of reasons first what you see in the
maker movement really inverts how our
traditional model of how we think about
engineering education so the traditional
engineering education is welcome to
college take some math take some physics
physics maybe some chemistry then we'll
teach you about signals and systems and
an assembly then come your programming
language of operating systems all the
way at the end you get to do a nice
project that puts it all together this
is turning it upside down people are
motivated to build some project and then
the four
sideration gets 80% there and then
something doesn't work and so that
generates a pull a desire for for new
knowledge but it has to be context
specific and just in time the second
interesting part here is that these
projects really combine design process
so the exploration of what one should
build in the specification what it
should be with fabrication the actual
realization of software electronics and
hardware components in one iterative
cycle third we're seeing just the new
digital fabrication toolset making its
way from industrial production into
end-user use and that brings a whole set
of questions with it namely that
amateurs just need different
abstractions and affordances from either
complete novices who may be in an
educational program to become experts or
existing experts who have a degree in a
specialty so I think all of these imply
need for new appropriate design tools so
what structures really most or all of
the research i'm going to show you today
is this research theme for for me to try
to understand what the 21st century
workshop looks like and let me give you
just two examples of really
inspirational prior workshops that many
of you have probably are familiar with
but i just want to bring to mind the
wright brothers workshop right inventing
the first maneuverable controllable
flight happened in a workshop that was
really informed by their work as bicycle
mechanics so it's manual power tool set
that you see here and of course just
down the street here Hewlett and Packard
garage that allowed them to to build
their first instrumentation amplifiers
and the whole world of information
appliances that that grew out of that
and so what should be in the garage the
workshop of the 21st century well I see
three core components the first is
sophisticated design software that
allows users to specify the intent at a
functional level of what
is they want to create that connects to
digital fabrication tools that then
autumn a automate some but not all of
the production task taking files from
design software as input and finally
ubiquitous electronics that are really
so fused in all of these products that
can be as easily programmed as web
applications can be today but then
interact with the physical world also
files drill sauce etc they're not yet
obsolete but we understand what we need
to teach people how to use them ok so
design software of course enables users
to create detailed plans and code how
their creation should look like and work
like and this is we really were a lot of
our work as computer scientists comes in
I and my students and collaborators
create the software that lets users
create the models and plans now
something else that I'm not working on
but which enables this transformation
that we see to occur is everyone knows
Moore's law well I think there's a
second law at work that is slower but
may be as impactful and that is the
scaling down of industrial manufacturing
equipment to the point where it becomes
feasible to have one in your lab at a
local store and perhaps for some of
those machines also in the home now
granted desktop fabrication is it's not
nearly as powerful as a million-dollar
CNC equipment but the key is that will
be used by many more users for many more
tasks than the than the industrial
machines and finally ubiquitously
programmable hardware you know Moore's
Law at work not about scaling up in
terms of capability and power but
scaling down in terms of being
incredibly cheap running complete
operating systems etc on a couple of
cents of silicon and also being small
enough and energy efficient enough that
you can now integrate programmability
into any device whether battery powered
energy harvesting or
connected to two AC power all right so
I've been with my collaborators trying
to build and prototype this 21st century
workshop at the jacobs institute for
design innovation there's a brand new
building on Berkeley's campus we said
geographically and maybe also you know
in spirit right between computer science
and mechanical engineering we opened in
August 2015 so we've just finished our
first academic year this is roughly what
the building looks like so we have a
number of studios two of those studios
are never assigned for classes they're
always available for drop-in tinkering
and building but then we also hold
design classes either at the scale of
fifty or a hundred students and then
kind of sprinkled throughout the entire
building is digital fabrication
equipment multi-material and elastomer
printers laser cutting circuit board
milling kind of the the whole range of
what you hear have in room 36 and at the
is that right and at the at the prl
you're just a couple of quick
impressions of the the inside of the
building this is our first floor open
makerspace and this is what a classroom
would look like it is not open 24 hours
a day we open at 8-830 a.m. and we close
at 11pm during the day talking with our
professional machine shop staff they say
rarely do good things happen after
midnight in a machine shop so in a first
two semesters we've had about 15
different departments represented I
can't believe it but 50 different
courses took place and about enrollment
of 3,000 students so Berkeley is big at
the undergrad level and we kind of went
from zero to three thousand very very
quickly let me just highlight three
concrete projects here or four let's see
here's a
a project that came out of mechanical
engineering this is Daniel lemon
collaborators working with a local girl
who was born with a deformity on one of
her hands trying to take prosthetics
from something to be hidden to something
that she had a role in co-creating and
is proud of and wants to show off so her
superhero hand and this was done
together with the enable community kind
of an open source community of low-cost
prosthetics we just had our drought
restrictions lifted but don't get too
excited yet who knows what happens in
the next couple of years this was a
class project in my interactive device
design class of a water-powered fixture
level water flow monitor so mechanical
engineering student designed this 3d
printed impeller that has magnets on the
outside when water rushes through that
spins it induces a current in a copper
spool that's on the outside and that
produces enough current to power up a
micro control that has some Hall effect
sensors that will measure the flow rate
and then has a low energy radio to send
monitor those monitored levels to an
application where it can then be be
tracked and forwarded etc and this is
actually this is now a nice Berkeley
Stanford collaboration in that we came
up with the first iteration of this
design in class and then afterwards for
levis and some students took on that
design did another design iteration and
i believe it's now deployed in a
stanford dorm measuring water
consumption here's a more whimsical
example this is a rocking chair that
generates energy to charge your phone
while rocking and I liked it because it
just shows the the interconnectedness of
different skills right so someone had to
learn to well to put together a frame
that could withstand the weight someone
got really into woodworking to do those
compound angles of the back and then the
students found an expert in energy
harvesting to
just think through well what's the right
mechanism to extract as much energy as
possible out of that rocking motion
turned out it was a suspended pendulum
underneath the chair and so they then
did the the circuits for that and
there's also an ePaper display
integrated into the armrest and one last
one just to hint on that there are
tremendous applications in the medical
domain this is a project that where the
idea came from our collaborators at UCSF
where people with sensory ataxia lose
feeling in their feet and that means if
you think of it from a controls
perspective you're starting to walk
open-loop you lack feedback and that
leads to Falls which leads to injury and
further complication so the idea here is
fairly simple pressure sensors in the
souls of the of the shoes that then
wirelessly transmit the footfall signal
to the back to your back where you have
cell phone vibration motors apply to
your back to nerve endings that that
still work and it's quite amazing seeing
some demo videos how within 15 minutes
of having this device people rewire and
can interpret that signal and become
more more sure in their gate so once
again you see this connection of there's
some mechanical parts yeah custom
electronics and then quite a bit of
software as well alright so that's just
the first part of the talk you know
what's happening in the maker movement
in general and what's happening at
Berkeley in particular so now let me
connect this to particular research
projects in my group on building new
design tools for these domains and just
in case we run out of time at the end
let me just make sure I stated
explicitly that of course the majority
of this work was done by a fantastically
talented set of students and actually
some collaborators here at Stanford as
well so I want to give you just a brief
glimpse into three different research
areas related to the maker movement that
that we're pursuing at the moment
first one is prototyping tools for
interactive devices how can we may make
it more rapid to explore the space of
interactive devices the second one is on
learning and debugging tools and the
third area is on hybrid fabrication so
what lies in between the tools you pick
up at home depot today and a fully
automatic 3d printer so let us do these
one by one so guiding question for this
first area is how can we make hardware
prototyping as fluid as prototyping
graphical user interfaces well we've now
had decades of really good tools that
make it very quick to design screens and
link them together through interaction
events well first why might we care
about Hardware prototyping of
interactive devices I'd argue that there
are performance and virtuosity benefits
from tangible interfaces that just
hitting your fingers on a flat sheet of
glass cannot replicate so if you ask you
know really invested gamers they will go
into exquisite detail about the the
haptics and the feeling the capabilities
of their game controllers similarly djs
to this day prefer the physical
tangibility of playing with vinyl
records and and turntables over just
playing software on on your laptop and
you see this in interfaces for flights
for airplanes and flight simulators etc
so the whole space of why creating
tangible devices still matters in this
day and age so how are they created
today well if you look into what
industrial design labs publish such as
Microsoft Hardware you see 3d printing
is used ubiquitously to create looks
like and prototypes so they give you a
sense of the aesthetics and the
ergonomics but they're just pieces of
plastic right if you actually want to
turn this into a working game controller
well then
kind of very detailed a complex process
of electromechanical co.design has to
occur you do the circuit board then you
have to fit the circuit board in control
you have to make sure that all the
buttons and joysticks are exactly at the
right place and really you're when
you're doing that you're in complex cad
which is kind of at odds with the goal
of prototyping where you want to rapidly
explore the space and not already commit
to all of these design details do you
really not yet sure about so our first
stab at at this question how can we make
hardware prototyping more fluid took
motivation from tangible modeling so we
ran a user study where we asked our
participants to to sculpt various
augmentations for their for their
devices like a bike holder for your cell
phone and what we learned from that is
some things are really easy to express
using sculpting and while other things
push the boundary of your knowledge of
sculpting and are really much easier
expressed as annotations such as put a
joint here or this is where the complex
mechanism goes and so combining
sculpting and Anna and kind of
high-level semantic annotation we took
that as inspiration for a project called
makers marks where the vision was the
following if we give you some sculpting
materials and a set of stickers to
annotate the function the intended
function of your object you know that
should let you easily create things such
as this mocked up game controller where
you sculpt the shape and then you put
stickers on wherever you want particular
IO affordances to fall and if we then
give u equivalent electronic parts
wouldn't it be nice if we could
automatically then from that generate
the right kind of detailed design to fit
all of these pieces into your sculpted
geometry and give you a working a
controller so
the idea here is we start by sculpting
the geometry placing those annotation
stickers and then we 3d scan your object
and the annotations and we use a 3d
scanner that creates both geometry as
well as texture images we then take
those texture images and run computer
vision algorithms over those images to
locate the points where you place those
stickers so that lets us locate those
stickers in the 2d images and because we
know how the textures are applied to the
3d model we can project that back into
three 3d space of the scanned model we
can then say oh you place the joystick
sticker on the model so we can now reply
replace that by a digital model of the
physical part and check whether you
could actually place that part at that
point on the controller and then
automatically generate mounting geometry
so that we when we printed you can snap
that equivalent part right into your 3d
print so this is for example what a
process model would look like so we
generate cutouts where parts protrude
through your model we generate fasteners
and mounting bosses and we also shall
the entire model so it's hollow on the
inside and generate suitable lips to put
the pieces back together so for in order
for that to work we need to create these
models for physical parts right so we
need the rough geometry we need the
clearance kind of how how much space it
needs to move around and we also need a
definition of how you would mount that
geometry in in a shell once we've
processed the model we then 3d print and
then afterwards the user you know just
takes these off-the-shelf electronic
parts snaps them in and ends up with
with a working device so we're not
talking about the software here right
the stuff the interaction still needs to
be defined but at least there are
already reasonable tools for for that
step so the key idea here is that our
maker expresses the shape intent through
sculpting and the functionality the
interactive intent through this
placement of marks and the tool then
automatically handles the detailed
geometry modification now the main
hurdle here might be you might think is
that we actually need these 3d models
for all of our electronic components
otherwise we can do the automatic
processing right well but it turns out
if you look around vendors for
mechanical parts already give you all
these CAD models so if you go on mcmath
mcmaster which is you know the
predominant source for parts for
mechanical engineers the vast majority
of parts they sell already come with CAD
models in various forms so we actually
don't think that is too big of a hurdle
in practice yes it has to be done for
each component once but vendors actually
have a financial interest into
generating these models alright so the
first step as at this problem was to
make it easy to snap in pre-existing
PCBs that you know someone already
created in kind of a plug-and-play
electronics toolkit so our second
question was well it seems that you know
3d printing will likely in the near
future have the ability to print
conductive materials as well so can't we
just print all of that connectivity into
the model right as we print the model
and then just add all of these
components individual components in the
end so here was kind of that that vision
that you know maybe we can create these
interactive objects like this touch
sensitive Stanford bunny by just
printing the whole object and inserting
some LEDs at the end and so the idea is
that actually inside of the model you
basically do 3d 3d circuit board routing
and connect all the different input
output points automatically so we built
a this is a little washed out a lot
washed out we built the design tool that
basically allows you to create these 3d
conductive routes through the insides of
objects by only specifying very high
level intent like route something from
this point on the surface to this other
point of the surface and we then figure
out appropriate routes that don't
intersect the that don't exit the
geometry and that don't intersect other
paths now the vision here is that you
can print this all in one go the reality
is that we didn't have such a machine
available at the time so we resorted to
a manual process which is you print all
of this you dissolve the support
material inside of the pipes and then
you just fill it with a conductive epoxy
or conductive paint and that led us to
generate a bunch of different working
models such as this so we're working
with some neuro scientist who are very
interested in different models of of
brains of different species so we could
generate this interactive brain and
other interactive objects and also we
have a different algorithm for basically
controlling the shape of the path inside
an object so you can create these neon
art objects now we weren't looking too
far into the future because we knew this
technology was coming down the pipes and
so now in our lab just over the last
couple of months we've had one of the
very first Vox late printers which
actually has a syringe in addition to an
extruder that can deposit this
conductive material right through the
middle of the print so that manual
process will go away
and we're really lucky also to work with
autodesk on this project and you can
actually find this pipe tool right now
for 3d circuit board right routing in
Autodesk smash mixer which is a free
kind of mesh modification tool all right
now let me take a third run at the same
problem just to maybe also show you our
thought process in the lab of not
thinking you know there's only one
solution to a problem but really
exploring a space of alternate solutions
what if we didn't have to put any PCB
inside what if we could take a piece of
plastic and transform it from a passive
piece of plastic into an interactive
device by only adding one extra
ingredient kind of think of a super
sensor that that could just detect
everything a user does with that game
controller so this is the clip you
already saw at the very beginning of the
talk our super sensor is a camera so we
take a camera we integrate it into a 3d
printed device and then we do computer
vision on the inside of that device and
interpret the movements of you know the
users pushing buttons are moving a
joystick in to turn those into
interaction events and let you control
games and other applications with it
alright so how does this work so so on
is an add-on to just a commercial CAD
package we use solidworks in this case
but there's nothing particular about
choosing SolidWorks so you have your 3d
model of the device you're building and
then you add a virtual camera into that
model and our virtual camera has the
right dimensions but it also has the
camera parameters like the the field of
view so you take our virtual camera and
you mate it with your with your
controller and you can already see what
that lets us do is we can now run a
simulation what of all the different
input components on this device are
actually visible by the camera
so things in green we can just track
with computer vision right away now
unfortunately there are also these other
components in red that are not visible
to the camera so what do we do about
those so this is where you know the
naive solution doesn't work so you got
to be a little more clever
algorithmically and our key lever here
is that we haven't printed this yet this
is just a digital model right so we can
modify the shape and the geometry of
that model to make the computer vision
task easier so camera here is in green
the field of view in light blue we have
a button here that is not currently
visible but we can take the end of that
button and just extrude it until it
falls within the field of view of the
camera so let me make that a little bit
more concrete here is a model of you
know a fairly complex object with
buttons on all possible sides we can
just run this extrusion check over it
and then extrude all the buttons to
various varying degree till they all
fall into the field of view of the
camera now that works sometimes not
always consider this button here if we
just extrude it straight down and ever
meets the field of view but here comes a
just you know elementary graphics into
account we can start raycasting race
from the camera into the scene and
bounce it off the boundary the shell of
the object so we take these rays bounce
them off the surface normal of our shell
and then we look at rays that hit the
component we want to track what do we do
with these rays well wherever those rays
hit the boundary of the object if that
surfers were to be specular right then
raise would also reflect from the object
back from that point into the camera and
so what do we do well we tell the maker
to glue craft mirrors into those
locations on the inside of the object so
kind of a theme that appears here is
use automation whenever possible but
don't discount the possibility of being
able to go quite a bit further if
there's just a little bit of manual
labor involved as well so injecting
conductive ink or gluing mirrors in the
right spot at the right time so then you
print the device if you have a single
color printer then here's the highly
technical step of highlighting the ends
with a piece of sharp with a sharpie
marker we've also printed on on multi
color printers so you can have these
marks that are easier to track by the
camera you can automatically print them
in a different color right now the trade
off of that is you know that's about an
order of magnitude more expensive to
print in multiple colors than in a
single color alright so then we have the
model and we add the camera the camera
comes with its own ring lights to
illuminate the inside of the object and
then the vision tracking is done through
interactive calibration so our CAD model
will highlight a component say the
slider and we say please move it through
its range of movement and as you do that
we can in real time build up a model of
in this case blob tracking you know from
minimum to maximum position now you
might you might ask why do we actually
have to do this calibration we have the
model of the camera and we have the
model of the geometry we should just be
able to infer all of that and that just
comes down to the limits of the
precision to which you can actually you
know manually screw that camera in and
if the lens is perfectly centered so
it's safer to have calibration than to
just infer you know they're the right
answer so for some components we do blob
tracking for others like the scroll
wheel and enter trackball we do optical
flow so these are really just off the
shelf computer vision algorithms that
work perfectly adequately here so in
addition to to these game controllers
we've also built you know various mice
and something that's near and dear to my
heart as a form of musician and DJ is DJ
controllers now just a quick word on
evaluation here we kind of proceeded in
two different direction to get some
triangulation of how of the limits of
this technique so on the one hand we had
a lab study where we brought in
mechanical engineering students so
students who already knew SolidWorks
said here's how this technique works
please design us a DJ mixer that
leverages capability and they were all
able to to do that within the span of
two hours or so and they were actually
quite clever in putting the camera in
different unobtrusive locations and
manually working with this technique of
placing mirrors so for example you can
have the camera in the top so it bounces
off the bottom and reimage is the top so
I have a little wider field of view now
what we also did is we then went to grab
cat and just downloaded a whole bunch of
models that were tagged with interactive
device and we did the analysis of
loading up that model positioning our
camera could we with our techniques
sends all of the inputs and outputs and
so things that are DJ mixer sized yes
game controllers 8 out of 10 yes but
there were some where it was not
possible and so wherever you have you
know inputs that are kind of satellite
to the main core of the device and only
connected through thin channel a single
balance will not make those visible so
you could extend that technique to go to
multiple bounces but it's just the
caveat here is this will not work on any
arbitrary model but I think for
prototyping actually while the designers
still in the loop right that can we also
be a conversation of can I easily modify
my model to make the sensing technique
work alright so key ideas for this part
use vision sensing as a super sensor on
the inside of fabricated objects and
then this is co design of the geometry
and the sensing technique so we can
modify the shape
to create an easier computer vision
model which is the flip side of what
computer vision research usually does
right which is pointing the camera on to
an arbitrary seen out in the world and
trying to understand that scene and
we're saying no no we actually control
the environment that you're looking at
so how can we make that environment
better so that existing algorithms will
perform better you cannot just do this
with vision so very quickly let me tell
you here's the same conceptual approach
but a different sensing modality so
instead of using your camera as a super
sensor you can also use a microphone as
a super sensor so our idea here is we'll
3d print input components with a time
mechanism so that it some sound is
created some vibration is created
whenever a user provides input so take
this button there's a plunger and then
we 3d print this time so as you press
down that time gets deflected eventually
it'll slip and then will vibrate back
and forth and so if we now put a contact
microphone on that 3d printed piece of
plastic we can pick up that vibration
and the basic intuition here is that
tines of different lengths will vibrate
at different characteristic frequencies
and so if we generate tons of different
lengths we should be able to distinguish
different inputs so you can not only do
this with buttons you can do that for
example with sliders as well and so what
are the different variables that
determine the characteristic vibrational
frequency of a time well its breadth
thickness and length and this is
basically a vibration of a can't you let
cantilever beam right so there's a
closed form solution which is the
fundamental frequency depends on
material properties
so density and Young's modulus and on
geometry of the time but the nice thing
here is we have this closed form
solution we don't need to train our
system there's no machine learning
involved here there's just some simple
signal processing and we already know
what kind of frequencies were looking
for so what we do is we run real-time
win doing over the incoming sound do the
FFT to look at the spectrogram and then
what you find whenever a tine is struck
there's this transient region where
there's just activation across the
spectrum it's a big noise right when the
tine slips but shortly afterwards
there's the steady state and in the
steady state one single frequency
clearly comes to the fore so that is our
F 0 and so the algorithm is very simple
it's do an onset detector till you see a
whole bunch of energy then wait x
milliseconds till the transient is over
and then look for the dominant frequency
afterwards here's some technical
evaluation so we tend to do very well in
the 1000 to 2000 Hertz range and then it
gets traumatically worse afterwards and
that has to do with the fact that as you
tines get shorter the energy and the
time for for which they vibrate becomes
increasingly shorter and so that window
after the transient to look for the
characteristic sound becomes shorter and
shorter becomes harder to harder to find
alright so that was a quick overview of
prototyping tools for interactive
devices that's mostly work that's
already been published in the last two
or three years I'm now going to get to
the experimental part of this talk where
I'll show you some unpublished work
that's really hot off the presses and
hasn't been really I've shown it once
before so you're a second time you ever
see this so work in progress caveat
emptor so first
you know tell you about work we're doing
in tools for debugging electronic
circuits so who in the room has bread
boarded circuits on on one of these
breadboards before almost everyone yeah
so at Berkeley if you're any kind of
computer science major you will take to
intro EE classes and build circuits of
one of these and just to be clear so you
build circuits on these the connectivity
looks like that if you haven't seen a
breadboard before so everything that's
plugged into a row is connected and then
the power buses are also connected up
and down now breadboards arose in the
70s as an answer to the question of how
can we rapidly plug together different
discrete components to get a working
circuit so they are fantastically
successful in that they've become
synonymous with prototyping electronics
but they have a couple of issues right
so if you build anything of any
complexity it becomes very hard to
understand whether what you've built is
actually what you want it to build so
they can be loose wires it can be power
issues often there might be questions of
component polarity have I pluck morality
or a capacitor in the right way you can
just wire things incorrectly to the
wrong row or pin and sometimes
components can also break that tends to
be the first student hypothesis it's not
usually the most likely hypothesis but
yes broken components exist as well so
what's the approach for debugging these
circuits well it's point wise
measurements right you make a single
hypothesis of what's wrong and then you
break out the multimeter and measure at
the point in the circuit that
corresponds to that hypothesis you can
do it with a multimeter or with an
oscilloscope now our research idea here
is that point measurements require you
to already have a
hypothesis about what the problem is
with the circuits we know from studies
of programmers that non-experts are not
all that accurate at generating
reasonable hypotheses the first time
around so how about we replace point
measurements with ubiquitous
instrumentation that means measure
everything all the time and based on
those measurements foreground likely
problems with the circuit and if you
then also have some model of what the
circuit is that someone is trying to
build right then you can relate the real
world measurements you just obtained on
the breadboard with the model of the
circuit and how it should be working so
here is our toast board the Augmented
breadboard there are on the board itself
there are LED bars that that show you
voltages at every row kind of Institute
but then we also have a software client
that highlights those voltages and in
that software client you can then also
create a model here's the schematic of
what my circuit is and we can then use
that model to automatically debug your
circuits so for example here various
warning signs show up this led may be
inserted backwards or broken how do I
know the voltage drop across these rows
is not what I would expect and so you
reverse the LED and we update the
measurements the warnings go away
alright the idea here behind that board
is we take a regular breadboard and then
we connect it to a multiplexer scan
chain where we row scan every single row
of the breadboard continuously then we
have another small microcontroller
underneath the breadboard where we just
take all those measurements and forward
them to software and in the software
then we can have the model of the
circuit
so here's the the PCB we manufactured
for that you take a regular breadboard
you peel away the foam backing on the
back and you just adhere it with a
conductive z-axis transfer tape to this
PCB that has exposed exposed conductive
rose and then we just have this
multiplexer cascade which basically with
one analog pin allows you to scan
through all the different rozon on the
breadboard and as I mentioned so we have
both on board feedback that lets you
determine simple simple errors like
these two rows are lit up I thought I
was connecting that wire to the resistor
there should only be one roll it up and
then in software you can get more
complex debugging based on expected
behavior of the circuit so we just got
this working three or four weeks ago and
are looking to deployed in in classes
this fall alright in the remaining three
minutes I'll just quickly touch upon
some other ongoing work on hybrid
fabrication tools so we're really
interested in the space of
semi-automatic fabrication so think
about the degree of automation and
intelligence that you find in in
products a hammer has no automation and
no intelligence it's all in the wielder
on the other hand a 3d printer is
completely automated right you just
download instructions and other than
some manual setup and cleaning
afterwards the rest is automated you can
add a motor and you end up with some
degree of automation but still no
intelligence so what's in this space in
between
have two projects ongoing in the group
right now one on augmented power tools
and one on cnc decoration so with
augmented power tools here the key idea
is let's awed meant common tools with
state sensing displayed feedback and
network connectivity and then show
continuous feedback based on those
sensing for skill training so how do I
become a more proficient user of the
tool and use the network connectivity to
allow you to download more complex
programs sequences upper of operations
that you want to accomplish not only on
one tool but maybe on a whole whole
ecology of augmented tools so our
augmented drill has basically cellphone
distance sensors in the front that gives
you a distance and also an angle to the
plane of your work material some
computation and then a laser projector
for feedback so what does that let you
do well you can for example drill a
blind hole to a target depth of you know
exactly 12 millimeters and on the side a
little harder to see there's also
orientation feedback that shows you
whether you're actually perpendicular
perpendicular is maybe the easier case
but sometimes you have to let's say
drill at a 45-degree angle and
estimating that freehand is quite
difficult now many operations actually
in in woodworking and carpentry are
really operations that sequence multiple
tools together so you drill you cut
something then you drill and then you
join multiple parts and so we have a
complete description language for these
types of operations that can be permit
erised so you a user can or a creator of
plants can you know create these and
give the user freedom of how to
instantiate these plans so in addition
to the drill you can imagine augmenting
all kinds of other tools so for example
here's an augment that saw that has
descent measurement so how steady
you cuttin which impact surface finish
and then also has distance measurements
so digital readouts are quite common on
many machines but this distance
measurement can be tied to the goal of
what you're trying to cut right we can
load the instructions into the saw and
give you feedback based on that so
here's just a quick clip of that in
action basic gives you feedback now stop
your overshot and so we're working
through a range of different building
projects right now and and studying how
end users benefit from these tools so
let me show you one more we've become
interested in emerging hybrid practices
that really merge manual work with C&C
automated machining so they're beautiful
you know antique vases that have three
now modern 3d printed parts or various
surface decorations and so we focused on
the problem of CNC surface decoration so
here the key idea is well 3d printers
are great if you want to create
something entirely from scratch but what
if you know able makers to modify
existing objects so objects they already
care about they have some emotional
attachment or they have they're made out
of materials that you can't yet 3d print
so our first foray into this area is
digital surface ornamentation we're
going to once again we use 3d scanning
as a core step and then allow so we're
going to 3d scan some existing object
and then allow you to modify it using
various digital authoring methods and
then leave the execution to a CNC
machine so the idea is that we scan some
existing object like this manually
created sculpture and then for this
project we actually created our own
machines so these machines don't exist
yet but it's almost trivial to convert a
consumer-grade 3d printer into a
decoration
machine basically what you do is you
replace one linear axis with the
rotational axis and then you add an
engraver bit holder in store or a pen
holder this can also work with other
machines this is an off-the-shelf router
that can also do the same job so the
idea is we scan your object and then
that object may be really complex right
but we have a 3d model of it so we can
from that 3d model automatically
generate mounting geometry that will
hold an object of an arbitrary size and
shape securely in the declaration
machine so we 3d print these custom
mounts and then sorry we seem to have
lost the key part artists begin by 3d
scanning they can choose to author a
design so we're scanning that the object
and then you can author yo augmentation
in either just paint on an object this
is fairly straightforward and also
important vector graphics to map onto
the object surface as in other design
software but in in addition to painting
there's also a live we experiment with
live engraving so you paint in real time
and basically with like a five-second
delay or so we start engraving on an
actual object and that allows you to
really bridge that gap between the the
virtual representation and the actual
physical object or because we have a 3d
model we can also print it out at a
different scale right so you can scan
something we can print it out larger you
draw on it and then we just scan it back
in extract those annotations and then
generate tool paths to engrave okay so
to sum up here how do these tools that i
present it help makers well key themes
from the users perspective they allow
you to describe your goal at a higher
level of abstraction this is what
computer science does really well right
llevate the level of abstraction that
you're operating on let the tool take
care of the mapping of the high-level
goals into low level operations but
there's also this tension between
whether what you create is a blackbox
abstraction or a glass box abstraction
so when complexity is inherent in a task
like understanding what that circuit is
in front of you then you don't just want
to jump to a higher level of abstraction
but you want to help people understand
by making the invisible visible so add
instrumentation and sensing and
visualize that extra data that is not
readily perceptual perceptible by the
user I think there's for a number of
years there'll be a great leverage by
intelligently combining utility out of
digital fabrication things you can do
automatically with carefully chosen
points at which manual labor will still
push the envelope of what you can build
and then there's this idea of receiving
guidance through context-specific
interactive examples and tutorial
formats just to some of the key
technical themes here integrated
approach to mechanical electrical and
software aspects of the project right
because so many of these maker projects
really unite the three so you have to
think of all three simultaneously that's
not just complexity it also makes some
problems easier like modifying geometry
to aid sensing then given a high-level
specification co-design geometry and
sensing approaches together right
combine computer vision artificial
intelligence digital signal processing
with geometrical design techniques then
there's the topic of ubiquitous sensing
right work with rich real world data
wherever possible so this includes
scanning and also scanning of 3d models
and also of electrical circuits and then
in general integrate 3d scanning as a
useful tool which we haven't seen a lot
of in in the maker movement but abstract
away from having to deal with hundreds
and thousands of polygons all right so
where's this going in the future in a
lab right now what we're really excited
out is actually advances in material
science that start to impact the maker
movement such as multi-material printing
printing a flexible elastomer object and
so where we have some of those prototype
printers by the time they trickle down
to the maker movement it will be a
couple of years but we want to have
those techniques ready now when they do
I also think that physical construction
debugging tasks are ideally suited to
augmented reality especially if you can
sense things about the circuit things
about the object it does not necessarily
mean strapping a big display to your
head right the augmented power tools are
another way of thinking about augmented
reality or the breadboard where you show
the right information in context just
not over late using using a head-mounted
display and in general we're really
interested in using jacobs hall as its
living lab to deploy and test these
tools so thank
couple questions yes um yeah sure about
that right so it looks like the error
detection that you're doing a kind of
analogous to for a runtime error and
software so I'm wondering like to what
extent do you think you can borrow from
ideas software debugging like pretty
much a space or something and to what
extent did it like necessarily going to
be different for however it so excellent
question and yes these techniques are
very much inspired by the kind of
affordances we already have in modern
IDEs right like constant compilation
giving you a red squiggly lines and so
very much inspired by that and actually
the next step for this project we'll
take it a lot closer to software
development as well because what I show
you is only about purely analog circuits
right what most people are building
right now our circuits hooked up to
computation to microcontrollers and so
the very next step that we're already
working on is pushing this boundary to
analyze software and circuit behavior
together and there the software
debugging techniques will become ever
more relevant yes one of the goals you
mentioned at the beginning was to use
these tools to help gain expertise in
actual manufacturing techniques like in
China but there still seems like there's
a big gap between this realm of tools
and like what if shenzhen factory would
actually have so how do you see that
yeah those yeah absolutely so just to
set the context again I think the maker
movement in general has the promise of
bringing more people into the design of
physical products which will then lead
them to gain manufacturing expertise if
they want to bring those products to
market the prototyping tools I've shown
you are there's definitely a gap because
they're the goal during prototyping is
actually not having to worry about all
of those manufacturing details so
abstracting away from all those
problems so you can get to the question
of well is this even the right design
earlier now there's a separate set of
projects that you can think about that
are about bridging the goal to
manufacturing some of those are
technical and some of those are social
in nature so for example we've had a
project in the past that is really
around connecting makers to people with
manufacturing expertise which right now
in the US tend to be retired machinists
right so how do you create the right
social you know community to enable
people who are quite likely remote with
the right expertise to give you input on
a particular design you're working on
the other part is the work that my my
colleagues have been doing is for
example capturing information about
different manufacturing processes and
giving you basically expert systems that
say i want to make the following and out
comes the recommendation you should
really use injection molding for that
all right i think the overall answer a
few more questions maybe a person here
thinking what what's that